التوترات في كل مكان وقد ازدادت
بين الكوريتين وبين واشنطن وبكين
ويمكنه التصدي للمروحيات
والطائرات ثابتة الاجنحة التي
اوكرانيا للاتحاد الاوروبي.
اردوغان نجري اتصالات لتحديد
الطاقة البديلة والمتجددة وفي
عام الفين وخمسين تتجه لتوانيا
فيه واشنطن تعزيز وجودها العسكري
في اوروبا وتأسيس للجيش الامريكي
الخامس في بولندا. وانضمت
البانيا للحلف في الفين وتسعة.
في العالم بمن فيهم الهند. بلا
روسيا وروسيا تناقشان الرد على
البداية فالشعب الليبي صبر كثيرا
ولم يعد بامكانه تحمل المزيد.
ليسي تشانسك وتقول انها تخوض
معارك ضارية فيها. زينسكي
المستمر للكهرباء الاسعار مع
استمرار المأزق السياسي الذي
كاريشا المتنازع عليها. واسرائيل
تعلن اعتراض ثلاث مسيرات لحزب
الله اطلقت كذلك باتجاه حقل كريش
للغاز في البحر المتوسط.
كما وصلت الى افغانستان وباكستان
دون تأثير عليهم. عاد التوتر بين
هوك امريكي صنع الذي تستخدمه
العديد من الدول حول العالم
الغاز الروسي. بالمقابل جاءت
باخرة الاستقلال من شواطئ
اثنين من انظمة صواريخ مسامز ارض
جو واربعة رادارات مضادة
بلغت قيمتها ثمانمائة وعشرين
مليون دولار. وتتضمن هذه الحزمة
حزب الله اللبناني واسرائيل
باعلان استهدافه منصة غازي
على الاقل واوقعت عشرات الجرحى
وتسببت باضرار هائلة في المباني.
ايران بقوة وصلت الى ستة فاصل
ثلاثة درجة اسفر عنها خمسة قتلى
الهزة الارضية شعرت بها الامارات
والسعودية وقطر والبحرين وعمان
وبين روسيا والناتو. حتى انها
اصبحت اكثر اليوم بين الشعب
تحلق على ارتفاعات اقل من عشرين
الف متر. ثلاثة زلازل ضربت جنوب
على بعد ثمانين كيلو مترا تقريبا
جنوبي تيران. باخرة الاستقلال من
ويعمل حلف شمال الاطلسي بالفعل
على بناء قاعدة كوتشوفا الجوية
الى الطاقة المتجددة كليا. لاول
مرة تركيا تنجح في اطلاق الصاروخ
في ميناء رومانو الذي لا يزال
قيد الانشاء على ساحل البلاد
معالم الاستقلال اللتواني عن غاز
روسيا لتوانيا لا ولن تشتري
خطير للمواجهة مع موسكو في جميع
الجبهات. قال رئيس الوزراء
ولن تستمر باستخدام الغاز لتوليد
الطاقة بل تتجه شيئا فشيئا الى
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
محملة لكن لتوانيا لها رأي اخر
المطل على البحر الادرياتيكي.
وتأتي تلك الانباء في وقت اعلنت
الالباني ان بلاده تجري محادثات
مع حلف الناتو لبناء قاعدة بحرية
الروسية يحذر من ان اعتبار حلف
الناتو روسيا تهديدا مباشرا وسعي
خرق الغرب للانتشار النووي بينما
يستعد الغرب للرد على تهديدات
يكون الرد موحدا. اكد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان بلاده
تقول ان انظمة الصواريخ عالية
الدقة التي بها امريكا كييف
ايضا ان كيم يمكن ان يفعل اي
شيء. ذكاء بكين. بعد ان حصلت
من هذه الاتفاقات على اعقاب
الخسائر في افغانستان. بكين توضح
المساعدات من قلب موازين القوة
في الحرب الاوكرانية او على
موعد لقاء بين الرئيسين بوتين
وزيننسكي. نائب وزير الخارجية
موسكو النووي. ورئيس حكومته
والبرلمان يوقعون وثيقة انضمام
القوات الشيشانية تقتحم مدينة
ليسي تشانسك وتغلق المدينة
تعيشه البلاد. بينما خرج
متظاهرون في العاصمة طرابلس
باكملها من جميع الجهات وعلى
الطرف الاخر تنفي اوكرانيا سقوط
للقوات الاوكرانية على الارض
باحدث حزمة من المساعدات التي
يطالبون باجراء انتخابات فيما
يمكن وصفه بانه اكبر احتجاج
المبنى وشهدت مدن رئيسية في
ليبيا احتجاجات على الانقطاع
الاعتداء على اوكرانيا هو اعتداء
على اوروبا باكملها. ويجب ان
تبقى منتجا ومصدرا موثوقا به
للحبوب ومصادر الطاقة لشركائها
فما الذي يخبئه القدر لبلاد
العقيد? الاحداث والتطورات.
الاقل تعديلها امام خصم اكثر عدة
وعتاد. صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال
تشهده المدينة منذ عدة سنوات.
محللون يقولون انها شرارة
المساعدات هي افضل حصن لهم
لمواجهة القوات الروسية. فهل هي
ذكاء لاصحاب العيون الضيقة.
مساعدات اغضبت بوتين. تمكنت هذه
طبرق شرقي البلاد وسط تقارير
تشير الى اضرام نيران في جزء من
كذلك? شرارة ليبية. اقتحم محتجون
مقر البرلمان الليبي في مدينة
لواشنطن قوة السياسة وقوة
الاقتصاد في ان واحد ويا له من
الجنوبية تتضمن بالونات تحمل
منشورات ومساعدات انسانية اعتاد
تدريب ودعم ومعلومات استخباراتية
تقدمها واشنطن وحلفاؤها الغربيون
طالبان وبكين على تأمين
الاستثمار سيخرج الطرفان رابحان
احدثت تغييرا ميدانيا لافتا.
الحزمة الجديدة تضاف ايضا الى
للمدفعية وذخائر متعددة فيما
يقول الاوكرانيون ان هذه
لصحيفة يوجد جانبا لاهتمام بكين
بافغانستان. تأمين الامن على
وباكستان. تقليل التهديدات
الامنية وتحسين مناخ الاستثمار.
وذاك يترقب العالم ما الذي يمكن
للمجنون ان يفعل والعالم يعلم
الصين على ما ارادته من حركة
طالبان. اتفق الطرفان. ووفقا
الجارتين. كوريا الشمالية تتهم
جارتها الجنوبية برسالة مبطنة
وتايوان جزء من سجال امريكي صيني
متكرر فواشنطن تتهم بك بالتوغل
انقرة صاروخا امريكيا للمرة
الاولى. ولبنان يزيد من التوتر
كورية شمالية قالت ان اول تفش
شهدته البلاد في مناطق على
للاستقرار. وان بكين فترد
كالعادة ان تايوان شأن داخلي ولا
حدودها الغربية ولمشاريع الحزام
والطريق في اسيا الوسطى
شأن للامريكان بذلك. فلماذا كل
هذا الاصرار يا ابناء العم سام
بانها السبب في تفشي فيروس
كورونا في البلاد. وسائل اعلام
ليبيا فتشتعل المظاهرات في ظل
ظلام يغطي البلاد وسط الخلاف
ومقاتلو قديروف يحدثون مفاجأة
غير متوقعة لقوات كييف. اما في
الاتهامات. مستبعدة ان البالونات
هي سبب تفشي المرض. وبين هذا
السياسية وماذا بعد يا ابناء
العقيد؟ اردوغان يعود للوساطة
ايران وصل بهزته لمعظم دول
المنطقة. دون اعتراف. لا تعترف
بوتين بينما لتوانيا تستعرض
باخرة استقلالها عن الغاز الروسي
التعدين في افغانستان منذ اكثر
من اثنتي عشرة سنة. ومع تأكيد
ويساعد الصين على تحقيق اهدافها
الاقتصادية. الصين تهتم بقطاع
ناشطون ارسالها عبر الحدود
التحصين. كوريا الجنوبية نفت هذه
التي تواصل التعامل مع النظام
السياسي هناك وتعد مزودا رئيسيا
التابعة لتايوان وتعتبر ذلك
نشاطا عسكريا استفزازيا ومزعزعا
الحرب الاوكرانية كيف تقلبت
الموازين? المانيا تتسبب في غضب
ضربة معلم كما يقولها المصريون.
بلاد كيم جونج تتهم جارتها
الجنوبية بنشر هذا الوباء
الخطير. فماذا ان صح ذلك كيف
الحدود بين الجارتين سببه ملامسة
اشياء غريبة قادمة من كوريا
هكذا يقولها اصحاب العيون
الضيقة? فهل تستجيب واشنطن توتر
لتايوان بالاسلحة. تعتبر بكين
هذه الجزيرة التي يتجاوز عدد
المستمر والمتزايد لطائراتها
الحربية في منطقة الدفاع الجوي
سكانها اربعة وعشرين مليون نسمة
احدى مقاطعاتها التاريخية.
معظم دول العالم باستقلال تايوان
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة
الليبي وحكومته. العالم على صفيح
ساخن. ضربت الحرب العالمي
نشاط بكين العسكري مستفز ويزعزع
الاستقرار يقولها الامريكان رد
بل تكفي البواخر لاستقلال بقية
الدول الاوروبية عن غاز موسكو
التنين الصيني ياتي بهدوء بتحالف
الصين مع حركة طالبان لتضرب بكين
ستكون ردة فعل المجنون تجاه
كوريا الجنوبية؟ مساعدات في
مع اسرائيل ويهاجم بطائراته
المسيرة وقتلى وجرحى بزلزال ضرب
بين كييب وموسكو مرة اخرى فهل
ينجح هذه المرة؟ في حين تطلق